in italy which like most of europe is
now battling a new wave of the
coronavirus
after being one of the hardest hit
countries early on it peaked at about 6
000 new cases a day but italy is now
dealing
with tens of thousands of new cases
every day chris livesay got rare access
inside a rome hospital that is
struggling to keep pace with the virus
a note some of these images are graphic
italian hospitals starting to burst at a
deadly price
footage from a naples er shows a man on
the bathroom floor
this one is dead says the person filming
this one we don't know whether he's
alive or dead
even icu's struggle as the body count
soars something we witnessed up close in
rome
so this is a patient who just passed
away from clover19
just this moment
so just two or three minutes ago this
patient was alive and now he's passed
away
unfortunately it happens says dr
sebastiano petrarca
more and more often as infections surge
across italy once the worst hit country
at the start of the global pandemic
italy was the first country in the world
to lock down nationally so that this
would never have to happen again
but italians eventually dropped their
guard says dr petrarca
who's now running out of icu beds
rome's covet hospitals are saturated he
says
it's exploding again and this time it's
spreading to the poorer south
with dangerously few hospital beds a
catastrophe
deja vu in a country that's already
served as a warning to the u.s
once before for cbs this morning
saturday
chris lipsay rome